[Applaus]
[Musik]
könnte ausgerichteten Mexiko der
Schlüssel dazu sein China aufzuhalten
und einfach zu ersetzen steht die Welt
vor einer neuen
Ära der nordamerikanischen Autarkie
einem Kontinent der alles hat genug
Rohstoffe und agrarflächentechnologie
eine gute Demographie und jede Menge
günstige Arbeitskräfte wird das Trio aus
USA Kanada und Mexiko den Rest der Welt
abhängen nun es wird wahrscheinlich
niemanden überraschen aber in
wirtschaftlicher Hinsicht wurden die
letzten drei Jahrzehnte vor allem von
zwei eng miteinander verflochtenen
Konzepten dominiert ich spreche
natürlich erstens von der Globalisierung
und zweitens vom Offshoring
[Musik]
mittlerweile sind wir alle mit diesen
beiden wirtschaftlichen und politischen
Phänomenen vertraut einerseits die
Grenzen der Welt in den letzten 40 bis
50 Jahren versprungen plötzlich begannen
waren Kapital und Menschen hektisch um
die Welt zu reisen und
Handelsbeschränkungen wurden immer
weiter abgebaut
überlagerten große multinationale
Unternehmen einen Großteil ihrer
Produktion in der Regel die weniger
komplexen Prozesse in Länder mit
billigeren Arbeitskräften und weniger
strikten Regulationen durch eine riesige
und hochkomplexe Logistikkette werden
die Produkte die heute auf dem Markt
kommen zum Beispiel als Smartphone in
der Regel aus Teilen Komponenten und
Technologien aus einer Unzahl
verschiedener Länder hergestellt
wenn wir jedoch über Globalisierung und
Offshoring sprechen müssen wir vor allem
über ein Land sprechen ein Land das sich
diese neue wirtschaftliche Realität wie
kein anderes zu Nutze gemacht hat ich
spreche natürlich von der sogenannten
Fabrik der Welt der Volksrepublik China
und an Gründen dafür mangelt es wahrlich
nicht fast 30% der gesamten
Industrieproduktion des Planeten Erde
findet in diesem Land statt dank dieses
Wirtschaftssystems ist China zu einem
gigantischen wirtschaftlichen und
industriellen Machtzentrum geworden seit
Jahrzehnten lassen sich multinationale
Konzerne auf dem Terretorium des
asiatischen riesen nieder um dort billig
zu produzieren und auf dem riesigen
Markt mit was 1,4 Milliarden
potentiellen Verbrauchern Fuß zu fassen
aber halt einen Moment denn dieser
Prozess verlangsamt sich jetzt die
Spannungen im Handel zwischen China und
den Vereinigten Staaten haben in den
letzten Jahren stetig zugenommen dabei
markierte Donald Trumps Einzug ins Weiße
Haus einen klaren Wendepunkt
[Musik]
im Februar 2018 begann die
nordamerikanische macht einen
Handelskrieg der dazu führte dass bis
dezember 2019 und 250 Milliarden
Produkte aus China mit einem Zoll von
25% belegt wurden und wer dachte dass
ich dies mit Trumps Abgang irgendwie
ändern würde konnte nicht weiter daneben
liegen die Regierung beiden behielt
seine Zölle nicht nur aufrecht nein
gleichzeitig hat die neue Beschränkungen
für den technologischen handeln mit dem
asiatischen riesen eingeführt
[Musik]
denn die Dinge entwickelten sich immer
weiter zum Schlechten die Bilder von
Pinks engen Beziehungen zu Wladimir
Putin und die ständigen Drogen gegenüber
Taiwan waren so etwas wie der letzte
Tropfen also meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer ja es stimmt dass die
Globalisierung in der Vergangenheit die
weltweiten Grenzmauern zum Einsturz
gebracht hat aber jetzt kommen sie
zunehmend wieder zum Vorschein
Spannungen in taiwanstein multinationale
Unternehmen das china-risiko zu
überdenken es wird eine neue Mauer nach
der anderen errichtet und wir sprechen
hier nicht nur von China dank der
globalisierten Wirtschaft sind auch
Länder wie Südkorea und Taiwan Leben
vielen anderen zu absolut essentiellen
Lieferanten für den besten geworden
im Falle Taiwans zum Beispiel geht es um
eine Insel der auf der die modernsten
Halbleiter der Welt produziert werden
Chips die für die Technologie und
Militärunternehmen der USA und die
Industrie Europas absolut notwendig sind
dieser Bedarf reicht von Apple über VW
bis locky Martin denn falls ihr es noch
nicht wusstet Taiwan oder besser gesagt
die taiwanesische Chip Industrie spielt
eine wichtige Rolle bei der Produktion
von hochmodernen Militärgerät wie
beispielsweise der F35 was würde also
passieren wenn picking eines Tages
beschließen würde Taiwan mit einer
Blockade zu belegen was wenn China doch
irgendwann beschließen sollte eine
Invasion der Insel zu wagen was würde
dann mit den globalen Lieferketten
passieren und falls du etwas eintreten
sollte oder einfach die Spannungen
zwischen China und den USA weiter zu
nehmen wie würden multinationale
Unternehmen dann reagieren wie steht es
um das geopolitische Risikoprofil dieser
Unternehmen bestellt oder genauer gesagt
um das Reputationsrisiko sollten diese
Unternehmen China Liebe verlassen es
wird viel über die möglichen
Alternativen nachgedacht bis hin zu was
sollen wir tun wenn es zu einem Krieg
kommt sollen wir unser Geschäft in China
schließen wie können wir unsere
Geschäftstätigkeit aufrecht erhalten und
mögliche Blockaden überwinden Jörg
Wuttke Direktor der eu-handelskammer in
China die russische Invasion in der
Ukraine hat alles verändert sie war
sozusagen eine tickende Zeitbombe was
früher als undenkbar galt wird jetzt als
möglich und teilweise sogar als
wahrscheinlich angesehen
jetzt inmitten der ersten großen Krise
seit 1978 war das China von Investoren
und multinationale Unternehmen zu einem
sehr unangenehmen Land obwohl sie einen
solchen marktlicht von heute auf morgen
komplett aufgeben können sind immer mehr
Unternehmen ernsthaft in Erwägung ein
Teil ihrer Produktion aus hinein andere
Länder zu verlagern tatsächlich hat die
Volksrepublik seit Beginn des
handelskriegs fast 4 % ihres Marktanteil
an den us-importen verloren um euch eine
Vorstellung zu geben das entspricht etwa
117 Milliarden Dollar und nicht nur das
im Gegensatz zum traditionellen
Offshoring liegt jetzt ein anderes
Konzept im Trend nämlich mir sharing das
heißt Offshoring in der Nähe des eigenen
Standortes vorzugsweise in benachbarten
Ausland das Problem dabei nun der Haken
ist der Mangel an Praktikantin
Alternativen ausreichende Zahlen für
US-Unternehmen gibt es nämlich ein Land
mit einer großen Zahl qualifizierte
Arbeitskräfte relativ niedrigen Löhne
die sogar unter den Chinas engagieren
und eine umfassenden Liefergarantie
sicherlich über welches Land ich spreche
denn der Titel dieses Videos kommt ja
nicht von ungefähr bevor wir jedoch nach
Mexiko abreisen würde ich euch gerne
einen Tipp mit auf den Weg geben den
alle reisefreudigen unter euch
beherzigen sollten es geht darum wie ihr
euer Englisch optimal entfalten und auf
ein perfektes Level bringen könnt vor
allem was die Aussprache angeht
schließlich ist der gerade auf Reisen
eine gute Aussprache des A&O um bei
seinem Gegenüber einem guten ersten
Eindruck zu hinterlassen und
zuvorkommender behandelt zu werden
häufig fehlt einem aber die Gelegenheit
dies effektiv zu üben vor allem bevor
man verreist ja bis jetzt es gibt
nämlich einen neuen innovativen und für
jeden zugänglichen Weg seine Aussprache
zu perfektionieren und zwar mit der
genialen Englisch App unsere Sponsors
Elsa das Besondere an ihr sie analysiert
die Fehler in deine Aussprache durch
modernste KI also man so vergleicht sich
deine Aussprache mit der eines
Muttersprache was bewertet deinen
Redefluss und deine Betonung zeigte alle
deine Fehler und erstellt aufgrund
seiner auf dich individuell abgestimmtes
stufenweises Trainingsprogramm aber
schauen wir uns doch mal an wie das
Ganze in der Praxis funktioniert
also ich habe jetzt schon den
Einstufungstest hinter mir und was
empfiehlt mir Elsa also irgendwie LR g
und the ja damit das weiß ich das ist so
meine Schwachstelle gucken wir mal was
der mir jetzt hier anbietet wie ich das
ganze verbessern kann also da kommen
erstmal Videos da wird das Ganze erklärt
aber die will ich jetzt auch gar nicht
sondern ich will gleich in die Übung
einsteigen so das ist das hier ist die
Übung erstmal easy ganz easy ich spreche
das jetzt mal bewusst falsch aus wie ja
darf man nicht so aussprechen
ich habe wie gesagt das ist unten
typische deutsche Aussprache weh ah
siehe da okay was kommt als nächstes
what ich spreche mal wieder falsch aus
what
bitte geht doch
ja ist halt falsch ne und ich kann jetzt
auf den Fehler drauf gehen und hier
steht eine Erklärung was genau ich
machen soll um den laut richtig
auszusprechen ich kann mir das sogar
vorlesen lassen
also probieren wir es mal richtig
auszusprechen when sehr gut mit diesen
auf deine individuellen Schwachstellen
fokussierten Trainingsprogramm kannst du
nicht nur deine Sprechweise und
Intonation gezielt korrigieren oder
nebenbei auch viele weitere Vokabeln
Rasen und Sätze für die tägliche
Kommunikation lernen Elsa bietet über
1600 Lektionen und 40 Themen von
Business Englisch über
Bewerbungsgespräche bis zum Flirt und
Reisebüro capula und alsanhäufchen auch
noch vielfältige Community-Funktionen
möchtest du z.B außer von der KI auch
von realen Menschen aus der ganzen Welt
lernen oder zusammen mit einem Kumpels
und Kollegen bei einem sprechwettbewerb
antreten das alles und noch er bietet
Elsa in eine bisher wirklich
konkurrenzlosen Angebot für
visualpolitikzuschauer in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video findest
du zwei Links mit dem ersten kannst du
Elsa kostenlos herunterladen und die Pro
Version für 7 Tage testen mit dem
zweiten gelangst du dann zu wirklich
fantastischen Rabatt angeboten die von
40% für das Jahresabo bis zu 85% auf die
lebenslange Mitgliedschaft reichen also
zögere nicht zu dir was Gutes und bring
dein Englisch endlich auf ein
geschliffenes Level denn perfekte
Aussprache hat noch nie geschadet und
falls Du uns etwas gutes tun möchtest in
der Beschreibung findest du auch eine
Spenden Link mit unserer Arbeit
finanzieren unterstützen kannst auf das
für euch auch in Zukunft noch mit vielen
interessanten Videos beglücken können
und nun lasst uns die Zukunft der
Globalisierung unter die Lupe nehmen der
Reisen nach Mexiko
das mexikanische Jahrzehnt
trotz aller Probleme und davon gibt es
wahrlich genug darunter Gewalt
Drogenhandel und weit verbreiteter
Korruption hat sich die mexikanische
Wirtschaft tatsächlich stark verbessert
und das ist keine zufällige Entwicklung
alles begann 1965 als das sogenannte
industrialisation program ins Leben
gerufen wurde
[Musik]
dieser Plan ermöglichte ist
ausländischen exportorientierten
Unternehmen sich in mexikanischen
Industrieparks niederzulassen und von
dort aus mit bestimmten Vorteilen zu
operieren zu diesen Vorteilen zählt ihr
zum Beispiel Zollfreiheit für die
Einfuhr von Waren es waren die
sogenannten makulaturas die Keimzelle
der mächtigen Industriestruktur die wir
heute in Mexiko vorfinden können dort
wurde zum Beispiel Mexikos Engagement in
der Automobilindustrie geboren die heute
mehr als 2 Millionen Arbeitsplätze
bietet was keine Kleinigkeit ist
tatsächlich ist der Handelsüberschuss
der mexikanischen Automobilindustrie
heute größer als der Überschuss den
Mexiko aus dem Ölhandel den Tourismus
und den Rücküberweisung von dem Ausland
Beschäftigten Staatsbürgern erzielt
doch neben dem Programm von 1965 gibt es
noch zwei weitere Schlüsselmomente die
zwei großen Wendepunkte der
mexikanischen Wirtschaft die zudem fast
aufeinanderfolgten
der erste davon fand in den frühen
1980er Jahren statt als das Land
beschloss den Protektionismus hinter
sich zu lassen und sich für ein neues
Wirtschaftsmodell zu entscheiden seit
diesem Entschluss hat sich das Land so
einem der stärksten globalisierten
Länder der Welt entwickelt es hat
Freihandelsabkommen mit mehr als 40
Ländern unterzeichnet genau eines dieser
Abkommen und der zweite große Wendepunkt
war natürlich das Freihandelsabkommen
mit den Vereinigten Staaten und Kanada
dieses Abkommen Taten 1994 in Kraft und
seitdem ist der Anteil der mexikanischen
Exporte am BIP von 12 auf und 40%
gestiegen heute ist Mexiko ein wichtiger
Produzent von Autos Luft und Raumfahrt
teilen und medizinischen Geräten
Unternehmen
hier Lego Rolls-Royce der Hersteller von
Flugzeugmotoren und viele andere
betreiben bereits große Fabriken in
diesem Land und was viele noch mehr
überraschen mag wir reden hier über den
sechs größten technologieproduzenten der
Welt und die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft
in Bezug auf Auslandsinvestitionen in
der Luft und Raumschiff ganz genau das
ist kein Scherz seht euch an wie sehr
sich die Dinge verändert haben
[Musik]
natürlich ist die enge Verbindung mit
der US-Wirtschaft der hauptaktuellen
dieser ganzen Geschichte um euch einen
Eindruck zu verschaffen der bilaterale
Handel zwischen den USA und Mexiko ist
in den letzten 28 Jahren jährlich um
durchschnittlich mehr als 8% gewachsen
und diese Dynamik scheint sich
keineswegs zu verlangsam sondern immer
mehr zu beschleunigen 2022 sind die
mexikanischen Exporte gegen Norwegen
sogar um 18% gestiegen ja in den USA
wird in der Südgrenze oft ein großes
Problem gesehen dabei bleibt ihr
wichtigstes Merkmal jedoch immer
unerwähnt ja genau jede einzelne Minute
eine Million Dollar wir reden hier von
fast anderthalb Milliarden Dollar
Warenwert pro Tag
und ja das alles sind legale waren denn
viele große US-Unternehmen haben sich in
Mexiko niedergelassen um etwas ganz
Ähnliches zu tun wie andere in China das
Schema sieht im Wesentlichen
folgendermaßen aus sie importieren die
fortschrittlichsten Designs und
Komponenten aus den Vereinigten Staaten
und Ländern wie Japan Teil waren oder
Südkorea in Mexiko wird das Produkt dann
fertig geformt zusammengebaut und später
wieder in den nördlichen Nachbarstadt
exportieren
das ist natürlich der Grundgedanke aber
im Laufe der Zeit beginnt viele
Unternehmen auch viel komplexere
Tätigkeiten in Mexiko auszuführen und
genau das erklärt warum dieses Land nach
China der zweitgrößte Lieferant der USA
ist das Verhältnis von Qualifikation zu
Arbeitskosten ist in Mexiko mittlerweile
viel besser als in China das heißt man
bekommt dort viel höherwertigeren Band
für seinen Bock und genau das erklärt
warum dieses Land nach China der
zweitgrößte Lieferant der USA ist und
beachtet bitte dass der Abstand auf
einmal gar nicht mehr so groß ist
während Chinas Anteil an den USA
Importen von 27 % auf etwa 22% gesunken
ist ist der Anteil Mexikos mit etwas 16
bis 17 % stabil geblieben mit anderen
Worten China ist zwar in aller Munde
aber Mexiko ist für die Vereinigten
Staaten fast genauso wichtig wie der
asiatische Riese na hat euch das jetzt
überrascht dann lasst uns kurz auf die
Bremse treten denn das Beste kommt noch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist ihr noch was wir über die
globalisierungskrise und den neuen
nearsharing-brand gesagt haben nun
Mexiko ist dabei das Maß aller Dinge für
die US-Industrie hat dieses Land extrem
viele Vorteile es ist zum Beispiel eine
riesige Quelle für relativ junge und gut
ausgebildete Arbeitskräfte es hat gute
Straßen und Bahnverbindungen einen
privilegierten handelszugang und zu
allem Überfluss in die
durchschnittlichen Lohnkosten bereits
heute niedriger als in China ja ihr habt
mich richtig verstanden schaut es euch
selber an
[Musik]
außerdem hat Mexiko neben der US-Grenze
auch Zugang zum Pazifik und gleichzeitig
zum Atlantik das bedeutet das ist eine
privilegierte geographische Position in
der hat weil es problemlos Komponenten
aus Asien den Vereinigten Staaten und
Europa gleichzeitig importieren kann und
wusstet ihr das mexikon achter Stelle
der Länder steht in den jedes Jahr die
meisten Ingenieure ihren Abschluss
machen wusstet ihr dass die Verschiffung
eines Containers von Mexiko nach New
York weniger als fünf Tage dauert
während die Verschickung von Hongkong
oder Shanghai bis zu 40 Tage dauern kann
mit anderen Worten wenn wir uns umsehen
scheint Mexiko bei weitem das bevorzugte
produktionshilfe US-Unternehmen zu sein
aber welche Auswirkungen könnte der
nirsharing könnten wirklich für Mexiko
haben können wir wirklich sagen dass wir
hier eine riesen Chance für uns haben
oder es ist nur eines Jena Konzepte die
in Mode kommen um sich am Ende des Tages
als heiße Luft zu erweisen
[Musik]
nun soll ich euch eine interessante
Tatsache verraten im Jahr 2021 haben
US-Investoren bereits mehr Geld in
Mexiko investiert als in China und zwar
in absoluten Zahlen nicht pro Kopf das
heißt pro Kopf steht Mexiko noch weitaus
besser da als China Schätzungen der Bank
of America zufolge könnten die
mexikanischen Export in den nächsten
Jahren um 30% steigen natürlich nur
falls ich auch Mexiko selbst auf diesen
Prozess einlässt wir reden hier von mehr
als 150 Milliarden Dollar an neuen
Exporten pro Jahr das würde dem Land
natürlich Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen
und eine Menge Wohlstand bringen und ja
das alles ist jetzt im greifbare Nähe
gerückt denn shisha-ping hat mit seiner
Politik und vor allem den drakonischen
corona-maßnahmen eine riesige Lücke
geschaffen die Mexiko jetzt nutzen kann
na klingt das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen zu gut um wahr zu sein dann
lasst uns lieber einen Moment innehalten
denn leider ist nicht alles so rosig
Mexiko scheint an der Schwelle zu einer
neuen goldenen Ära zu stehen wenn die
Dinge gut laufen könnten wir sogar vom
mexikanischen jahrzehn sprechen im
Moment könnte die wir tschaft dieses
Landes jedes Jahr problemlos um mehr als
5 oder sogar sechs Prozent wachsen aber
es ist auch möglich dass das Land diese
Chance verspielt oder zumindest nicht
voll ausschöpft und wisst ihr was genau
das könnte wirklich passieren also lasst
uns noch einen Moment in Mexiko bleiben
und das Hauptproblem an dieser ganzen
Geschichte auswendig machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein Stolperstein namens amelo andres
Manuel Lopez ortrador die Vorteile der
mexikanischen Wirtschaft scheinen auf
der Hand zu liegen doch wenn es dann mal
drauf ankommt scheinen die Dinge nicht
mehr so gut zu funktionieren oder
zumindest nicht so gut wie man es
erwarten würde so hat sich zum Beispiel
der Anteil Mexikos an den us-importen
seit Beginn des handelskriegs zwischen
den USA und China kaum verändert Chinas
Rückgang wurde vor allem von anderen
asiatischen Ländern ausgenutzt seht euch
mal dieses Diagramm an der größte Teil
der zuwechseln an die asianischen
Staaten Indien und Korea zumindest im
Moment stützen die us-importdaten nicht
die Ansicht das Mexiko einen netto nutz
war und nicht nur das seit 2015 sind
Investitionen in Anlage Kapital also in
Maschinen Fabriken Gebäude
büroseinrichtung und so weiter nicht
mehr gewachsen und seit 2019 sind sie
sogar gestumpft erschwerend kommt den zu
das Mexikos Wirtschaft in den letzten
Jahren eine Damen wenigsten dynamischen
in ganz Lateinamerika war und an dieser
Stelle müssen wir es ganz klar
aussprechen das ist vor allem
politisches Versagen und zwar auf ganze
Linie
das größte Hindernis Mexikos sein
Potenzial als Alternative zu China voll
entfalten zu können könnte also Mexiko
selbst sein tatsächlich ist der
Präsident des Landes selbst ein Gegner
ausländischer Investitionen eine seiner
ersten Entscheidungen war die Schließung
von prometico einer staatlichen Agentur
zur Förderung von Investitionen im Land
ganz genau er hat sie nicht etwa
reformiert oder ihr Verpflichtungen
auferlegt nein er hat sich ganz einfach
ersatzlos dicht gemacht außerdem weißt
du Infrastruktur enorme Mängel auf aber
die Regierung schaut trotzdem lieber weg
und hat eine vermutlich zu großen Teil
der öffentlichen Investitionen in
Projekte zweifelhafter Rentabilität
gestellt so wie zum Beispiel den
maja-zug eine Art Touristenzug und
natürlich sind Schlagzeilen wie die
folgende überhaupt nicht hilfreich
Zwölfter juni 2022 mexikonen
Privatunternehmen ins Gesicht und
bedruckt damit Jahrzehnte des
Wirtschaftswachstums 14 Januar 2023
Mexikos Hinwendung zur Autokratie sollte
die USA beunruhigen wollt ihr einen
konkretes zum Beispiel nun hört euch mal
folgendes an
lo hat vor die staatliche Kontrolle über
den öl-gas und Stromsektor wieder zu
erlangen zu diesen Zweck hat er keine
Sekunde gezögert zum Beispiel private
Kraftwerke mit Hilfe zweifelhafter
Motive zu schließen Brennstoff und
treibstoffimport terminals in den Häfen
zu blockieren neue Auktionen für die
coolen wasserstoffexploration
auszusetzen und neue private
Investitionen im Elektrizitätssektor zu
nehmen er will sogar ein Gesetz
durchsetzen dass die Stromnetzbetreiber
dazu zwingt dem vor der staatlichen
Elektrizitätsgesellschaft CFW erzeugten
Strom Vorrang zu gewähren obwohl dessen
Energie teurer und umweltschädlicher ist
seine Politik macht den Strom in Mexiko
derzeit um 40% teurer als in den USA ein
klarer Nachteil für Industrieunternehmen
wollte er ein weiteres Beispiel nun
leider habe ich noch viel mehr auf Lager
20 April 2022 Mexikos links
populistischer Präsident will Lithium
verstaatlichen um die staatliche
Kontrolle auszuweiten diese Maßnahme
bedroht das einzige bedeutende
lithiumprojekt in Mexiko und was soll
ich sagen
das sind nur ein paar Beispiele für eine
Dynamik die nur allzu bekannt ist am no
mag halt weder multinationale
Unternehmen noch ausländische
Investitionen deshalb ist er bestrebt
diesen alle möglichen Steine in den Weg
zu legen
wir sprechen von einer Haltung die
mehrere us-servatoren dazu veranlasste
Präsident beiden aufzufordern sofort
Maßnahmen gegen das zu ergreifen was sie
als Aggression gegen das
nordamerikanische Freihandelsabkommen
betrachten das Problem ist das all diese
Maßnahmen und die enorme regulatorische
Unsicherheit die amlodiert dazu führen
könnten dass das Land eine historische
Chance verpasst die Tatsache dass das
Wachstum schwach ist und die
Auswanderung von Mexikanern in die USA
zum ersten Mal seit mehr als 10 Jahren
wieder zugenommen hat ist kein positives
Signal
aber am Ende des Tages sollten wir doch
das positivste im Blick behalten Mexiko
scheint fast alles zu haben um ein
bedeutender industrielle und
technologischer Arm der westlichen
Volkswirtschaften zu werfen
immerhin herrscht in den Gewerbegebieten
und Industrieparks im Norden des Landes
großer Andrang und immer mehr
Unternehmen fragen sich ob Sie Ihre
nächsten Investitionen nicht lieber in
das Land ist die Kia der Tacos der
Mariachis und ist ewigen sommerslenken
sollten wenn Mexiko also seine Karten
richtig ausspielt die Unsicherheit
verringert seine Infrastruktur
verbessert und ausländische
Investitionen begünstigt könnte das
größte hispanische Land der Welt im
nächsten Jahrzehnt zu einem wichtigen
Akteur werden aber jetzt wo wir diesen
Punkt erreicht haben seid ihr an der
Reihe denkt ihr das Mexiko seine Chance
nutzen wird wird dies das mexikanische
Jahrzehnt sein und kann Mexiko zusammen
mit den USA und Kanada eine Ära der
amerikanischen Autarkie einleiten das
heißt unabhängig werden von China und
Europa was muss die mexikanische
Regierung eurer Meinung nach tun um
diesen Prozess voranzutreiben wie immer
sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon wichtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like heißt
mit euren Freunden vergessen
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit uns hält dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut bis bald
[Musik]